quand on parle des questions autochtones
on peut aussi avoir le sentiment que
l'on va de rapports en rapport que les
problèmes sont déjà connus on peut
penser au logement à l'éducation etc
qu'on connaît également les solutions il
y a eu notamment la commission erasmus
du saut en 1991 une commission royale
d'enquêté présidée par georges et
rasmussen ancien chef de l'association
des premières nations du canada et par
le juge de la cour d'appel du québec
rené dussault
frédéric cette commission à la fin un
travail considérable elle proposait
d'ailleurs un plan d'action pour réduire
ces inégalités auxquelles sont
confrontés les autochtones
effectivement celui d'un travail
considérable titanesque pendant cinq ans
ils ont rencontré des centaines de
personnes ils ont entendu quantité de
mémoire qui ont été délivrés lors du
passage de cette commission
qu'est ce qu'il en est ressorti et bien
en fait pas ni un ni deux ni trois
volumes et bien si ce volume pour un
total en fait de quatre mille trois
cents pages c'est énorme et dans ses
quatre mille trois cents pages on
retrouvait un peu plus de 400
recommandations alors qu'est ce qu'il y
avait principalement dans ses
recommandations
en fait cette fameuse commission royale
eh bien c'était quasiment un plan de 20
ans pour essayer de réduire les
inégalités entre autochtones et non
autochtones
et là on pensait notamment qu'il fallait
beaucoup miser sur l'éducation c'était
un des credo d'ailleurs de paul martin
lorsqu'il avait proposé ce plan là et on
voulait également créer un gouvernement
une espèce de troisième palier de
gouvernement qui serait fondée sur les
autochtones
or ça fait maintenant presque vingt ans
de cela et de l'aveu même de tous les
commissaires qui ont travaillé là dessus
quasiment rien n'a été fait rien n'a
changé n'était pas la première fois ce
n'est pas la dernière fois non plus
qu'on a proposé justement des solutions
à tout cette question effectivement en
fait il ya beaucoup de gens qui se sont
penchés sur la question des problèmes
autochtone par exemple si la frisonne en
2011 c'était l'ancienne vérificatrice
générale du canada qui avait examiné les
programmes fédéraux pour les premières
nations qui vivaient dans les réserves
et l'a constaté qu'ils avaient d'énormes
carences d'énormes lacunes dans
l'éducation le soin des enfants l'accès
à l'eau potable et le logement
on pense également aussi à un autre
rapport évidemment le commission en la
commission de vérité et réconciliation
du canada qui se penchait sur les
pensionnats autochtones et les
catastrophes que ça a généré
rapport publié donc cette année 94
recommandations on ne sait pas encore
s'ils vont être mises en oeuvre par le
fédéral et puis aussi il y à d'autres le
rapport officiel de l'onu par exemple
james hayes annales rapporteur officiels
de l'onu en 2014 qui a constaté que
l'écart entre les autochtones et non
autochtones d'amérique n'avait pas
changé en fait depuis 2004 et les
conditions socio économiques sont
toujours désolant pour les premières
nations mais alors aucun gain aucun
avancement dans son qu'un progrès dans
ces dossiers beyou certains progrès par
exemple le gouvernement canadien en 2008
a reconnu ces textes qui s'est excusé en
fait pour les pensionnats autochtones y
ait des victoires aussi devant les
courts la cour suprême par exemple qui
reconnu qu'il y avait une obligation
consulter les autochtones notamment pour
l'exploitation de leurs terres il reste
que l'optimisme est là avec
effectivement la volonté politique de
michel chouinard les instances mais en
même temps on a peur aussi qu'une fois
de plus ses rapports vont les prendre la
poussière sur une tablette quelque part
et ça c'est le grand désespoir des
autochtones merci frédéric
il pour en savoir davantage sur cette
tragédie pouvez consulter notre dossier
web vous voyez l'adresse à l'écran